c'è tra i cappelli di natale berruti
questo è il più brutto che appello di
natale che esiste fra è bruttissimo e
provinciale vetro di appello più brutto
esista nella vita ma di avere la testa
di td gabibbo per far centrare questo
avevamo scena una senza ciao
buon natale a tutti ciao ragazzi allora
questo innanzitutto il mio sfondo
vecchio perché sono tornato a casa per
le feste visto che ogni tanto anche io
mi ricordo di avere degli amici e dei
parenti
ragion per cui video di oggi lo faccio
con denise e la mia sorella più o meno
cioè insomma ci conosciamo da quando
siamo nati praticamente quindi e mia
sorella è un casino e la nostra famiglia
ho rubato il format a wil woosh deciso
di portarlo come speciale di natale ho
deciso di ascoltare proprio i vostri
vocali dove mi raccontate che cosa
vorreste per natale lo spirito natalizio
il primo messaggio di ginevra
troppa vive io vorrei per natale è un
piccolo favore da parte del signore che
mi tolga questa benedetta ansia mentre
guido perché sennò la patente la prendo
che ti fanno i 40 anni
questo bel regalo nel senso che almeno
lei la prenderà 40 io no mi ha neanche
tra quarant'anni alla prenda evidente
però ginevra ti siamo vicini martile
enia martile cioè martire non so se
chiamarla malattina oil eni annoiato in
oppure è una fusione tipo mart ilenia ci
manda questo messaggio
c'è stata una parte questa volta anche
gli strumenti musicali grandissima c'è
stata da parte di cui poi assoluto delle
pasticche le situazione degenerata libro
prima era martina e poi a cantà di legna
che il tuo desiderio si avveri tante
buone cose next antonietta niente
siccome avere una vita torna perché
avere quindi sia tantissimo e gli ho
chiesto se mi poteva mostrare farvi
ovvero atene metterlo sotto l'albero
papa ha detto che il sequesto di persone
punibile con il carcere
quindi un po prossimo messaggio di
jasmine ragazzi jasmine ci chiede sono
lor e ti faccio questo audio e gli ho
detto sinceramente per natale voglio
solo una cosa che ho sempre desiderato
ho sempre sperato in questi anni
in questi ultimi anni comunque un h
manca quel un cazzo di cosa che vuole
mai che si interrotto perché se no vero
rimaniamo nel family friendly una cazzo
di gioia a meno male che specificato
perché non era molto femminile è una
gioia ci stava se non era una gioia si
fermava prima era un casino luca luca yo
yo trattamento io per notare con il
router pantalla ciao luca ma vada via
eleonora eleonora già ha scritto subito
dopo mi sono già pentita chissà cosa
avrà mai detto le faccio un altro meno
volgare ascoltiamo invece quello base
vai eleonora dici che cosa vuoi per
mandare non so se sia tu babbo natale
visto che quello che so che erano un po
ambiguo però for caravano natale
quest'anno vi sono stato tanto buone
brava e timori ci chiede un gigante
grazie
solo per un giorno almeno per intentare
niente magari qualche taglia in più il
seno ma mancini grazie ancora di vedere
chi non sa stare con le fette di pan
grossi augurino grossi enormi auguri
angela vai dici che cosa vuoi per natale
tesoro caro babbo famiglie per natale io
vorrei un viagra per mia sorella che
tutti chiedono queste cose occupo mia
sorella problemi e deterrebbe il viagra
oltre favore darmelo
il viaggio magico è tutt'altro che ahimè
mai ciò dei fan che non stanno
appostando migliaia per gli uomini per
gli uomini quello ma scusa ma che cosa
ma cosa formate voi a natale diventa
anche se non vi do natalizio esce un
aroma family friendly magari lo vedono
le famiglie con la nonna al tavolo sai
di quanti insieme abbiamo meno di
famiglia il ragazzino all'anonima
guardare familiari ha preferito elano
andava sul pezzo del viagra e nonne che
state guardando questo video e famiglie
io vi giuro i miei video non sono così
sui miei fan che non hanno senso in
questo caso messaggio di sofia
vai 30 secondi questa lettera la guidano
nella letterina di natale
come prima cosa assoluta ho chiesto
all'ufficio di matematica mi sta capendo
niente coderno parabola rintocchi ecco
il piano parabola magari in arriva però
un offrire loro la signore si possono
chiedere i miracoli perché signore fa i
miracoli però se in matematica mi sembra
un po oltre il mirato difficilissima
come questo è un format di willwoosh ho
chiesto proprio a will bush se mi
mandava una letterina di natale quindi
adesso ascoltiamo l'audio di willwoosh
che cosa vorrebbe we wish per natale
proviamoci
caro babbo natale ciao sono io so che in
passato
ho avuto un ottimo rapporto perché
ancora non ho digerito quell'anno in cui
ha portato delle mutande e basta cosa
fosse successo della finanza ecco
grossardi ci sono rimasto malissimo ma
quelli erano bene ho pensato quest'anno
ti chiedo ok ascoltami di farmi trovare
una persona non ti dico con la quale
passare il resto della vita ecco questo
ottimismo l'abbiamo sepolto però ecco
una persona che non mi faccia venire la
voglia dopo due settimane di impiccarmi
per le palle erano da noi tutte francia
persone che vogliono i capezzoli
strizzati o quelli che sono dodici nomi
mente boni o ancora peggio quelli che
pensano ancora di essere kevin di mamma
ho perso l'aereo
ok facciamo che quest'anno troviamo una
persona centrata equilibrata con un po
di tutto è presente una sorta di buffet
all you can eat
ok grazie voglio bene dai che ce la
facciamo questo 2017 un anno pieno di
frustrati mamma mia quanta frustrazione
totale però vabbè trovare il bambino di
mamma ho perso l'aereo non è male come
dite che malinconia mogli impiccati non
so che gente frequenti willwoosh dio mio
mi dispiace spero che tu possa trovare
un sacco di felicità durante queste
feste prisco per di avere una famiglia
in bangladesh e lo vedo contento
vabbè il secondo messaggio viene da
giulia penna che ha deciso di mandarmi
anche lei una letterina molto più
sintetica 12 secondi però ce l'abbiamo
in casa ok
vai per questo felice natale desidererei
veramente tanto una bella botta di culo
che conta fi alliance o mi serve proprio
un bacione da giulia a botta sicura o
allega bongiorno se si bloccava il borgo
calamità ra brutto io vorrei una bella
botta
basta bene io sono contentissimo che i
miei amici mi abbiano mandato questa
letterina non lo farò mai più a babbo
natale ha chiesto di poter mangiare
senza ingrassare spero posso
accontentarmi
un bacio e non può averla solo una
persona al mondo sta cosa ce l'ho io e
basta
stefania ci chiede che come continuo a
sbatterlo contro ogni spigolo per natale
un mignolo nuovo mi sa che ogni volta
che è sbattuto con il migliaio sono il
comodino il signore non potrà
accontentarti in questo momento però è
che un maschio maledizione un maschio o
antonio dio mio antonio se la salvezza
caro babbo natale quest'anno vorrei
niente perché ho già tutto una persona
che sa quello che vuole
gli dà ci chiede per natale popoli
allora io per natale al mio ragazzo che
ha sognante in particolare che scelgono
borsa peccato che l'ha ordinata tipo
l'altro ieri quindi io per natale sotto
l'albero non troverò niente poiché non
fa in tempo ad arrivare lì niente natale
schifoso senza regali molto per me
torino adami che arriva dopo noi che
arriva ora gameboid tutto sul vassoio
mangia vita ha fatto ma è maestri
giuseppe si chiede guarda lo re io per
la torre non vorrei né soldi né giochi e
video che non vorrei soltanto e dico
soltanto crediti universitari tanti
feriti vertità ti capisco la sua
situazione purtroppo giuseppe proviamo a
chiederti a chiedere dei crediti
universitari se gli chiedi a me te li
tolgono però va bene serena area rettore
style ad acerno brilla sarà da germain
caro babbo natale io come riconosce di
natale vorrei una per i tour in tutto so
ma mi piacerebbe averne una bisogna
parlare perché non c'è abbastanza corna
next gabriel vai cabria dici cosa vuoi
per natale è stato chiarissimo molto
chiaro grande
speriamo che si vuole essere arrestato o
portato via sente l'ambulanza esatto
amin dc per natale non vuoi lunghe
voglio una ragazza bolognese la marca
che abbia un culo enorme per a parigi
per al rais non vogliono che voglio una
ragazza che mi piace la mappa ha chiuso
a me sta a capitoli e dopo non la voglio
fare bene ma non sarebbe riuscita mai ad
andare avanti ha detto va bene va bene
ragazzi noi concludiamo qua anche perché
abbiamo ascoltato un sacco di messaggi
vocali mazza babbo natale c'è un compito
veramente arduo spero che i vostri
desideri compreso quello di eleonora
severino ci vediamo ti inventi questi
che superi i modi questo così così
sembra molto più natalizio di sla fede
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto come è un mi piace buon natale
a tutti e noi ci teniamo ad un prossimo
video sa che non ho portato il
telecomando lasciato a milano da ragazzi
[Musica]